aujourd'hui la tnt propose 27 chaînes
gratuites
une profusion de programmes qui tranche
avec les débuts de la télé dans l'après
guerre
la télévision n'a qu'une chaîne et c'est
un monopole d'état
la priorité fournir aux territoires une
couverture et sienne dont il a bien
besoin
les habitants de nogentel vient
d'arriver le camionnette qui débarque à
un matériel barbare ils lui demandèrent
réellement à quoi pouvait bien servir
cette espèce de perchoir au pigeon que
londres est les vers le ciel à la fin
des années 50 un million de postes de
télévision équipe les foyers français
le petit écran entre dans les moeurs la
rtf service public de l'audiovisuel
projette alors la création d'une
deuxième chaîne
personnellement je crois qu'une seconde
chaîne d'état dans les circonstances
actuelles et celles qui la plus rapide
la plus facile et la famille dalet sur
pied la deuxième chaîne sera donc lancée
en 1964 mais il faudra attendre encore
huit ans pour obtenir la troisième
chaîne en 1972 une nouvelle venue placée
sous le signe de la couleur et des
régions elle ouvrira ses portes sur la
promesse qui disons le jusqu'à présent
la plus s'exprimer comme elle le devrait
malgré l'éclatement de la rtf en 1974 la
télévision française reste entièrement
public et conservent trois chaînes
pendant encore dix longues années
jusqu'à ce que en 1984 evènement dans le
paysage audiovisuel français la
naissance aujourd'hui de la quatrième
chaîne canal+ une brèche dans le
monopole d'état
voulue par l'état qui donne l'impulsion
de la libéralisation du paysage
audiovisuel
en 1985 le président mitterrand annonce
ainsi la création de nouvelles chaînes
privées il y aura d'autres chaînes
les chaînes verticale sur les grandes
chaînes nationales les 4 nouvelles
chaînes qui se créé pendant les années
80 canal+ l'a5 tv6 puis m6 ont pour
modèle les chaînes du service public
national et généraliste durant les
années 90 hormis le remplacement de l'a5
par arte et la cinquième
pas de nouvelles chaînes hertziennes
pour les téléspectateurs l'arrivée de la
tnt en 2005 et donc une révolution
depuis 15 ans rien n'avait changé
et là tout à coup le nombre de
programmes qui leur est proposé
gratuitement va être multiplié par trois
le nombre de chaînes gratuites pas sans
quelques mois de 6 à 18
aujourd'hui l'offre télévisuelle en
france ne cesse d'augmenter
27 chaînes gratuites actuellement sur la
tnt quant aux chaînes françaises
diffusée sur le câble le satellite et
internet le csa en recense 292
[Musique]